'S >> Announcer: AMERICANS
HELD HOSTAGE, ABANDONED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES, DAY 68.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
YEP, 68 LONG DAYS, OUR
AMERICANS, FELLOW AMERICANS,
THEIR FAMILIES, OUR ALLIES,
THOUSANDS OF GREEN CARD HOLDERS
ALL TRAPPED BEHIND THE ENEMY
LINES OF THE TALIBAN, ABANDONED
BY YOUR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE REPORTS,
ONE YOUNG WOMAN BEHEADED BY THE
TALIBAN.
WHY?
BECAUSE SHE ONCE PLAYED FOR THE
AFGHAN NATIONAL VOLLEYBALL TEAM.
AS WE SPEAK, ALL FEMALE ATHLETES
IN THE COUNTRY, THEY ARE BEING
HUNTED DOWN BY THE TALIBAN,
FEMALE ATHLETES ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO EXIST IN THE NEW ISLAMIC
EMIGRANTS OF AFGHANISTAN.
OH, THE ONE THAT JOE AND
JEN PSAKI SAY ARE SO
BUSINESSLIKE AND PROFESSIONAL.
ALL ACCORDING TO JOE, RIGHT?
NOW, THE PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
TAKING OFF THE TERROR WATCH
LIST.
JOE BIDEN IS NOW ALLOWING FORMER
TALIBAN LEADERS, TAKING THEM OFF
THE WATCH LIST, AND ALLOWING
THEM TO COME TO AMERICA.
DOES HE THINK THEY'VE CHANGED?
ANY INDICATION THEY HAVE
CHANGED?
I HAD DOUBTED THEY CHANGE.
BIDEN HAS SIMPLY MOVED ON, OR IN
HIS WORDS, TURNED THE PAGE.
AFTER ALL, HE HAS MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT, LIKE
REMINISCING ABOUT HIS LONG TRAIN
RIDES TO DELAWARE, VERY
IMPORTANT MATTERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ANGELO NEGRI WAS FROM -- CAME
UP TO ME ONE DAY WHEN THEY JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT I HAD FLOWN
1 MILLION SOME X NUMBER OF MILES
ON AIRCRAFT, AND COMES UP AS I'M
GETTING IN THE CAR AND GOES
"JOE, WHAT ARE YOU" -- I THOUGHT
THE SECRET SERVICE IS GOING TO
SHOOT HIM.
NO, NO, NO, HE'S GOOD, HE'S
GOOD.
TRUE STORY.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY MILES HE DID
AMTRAK?
I DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA.
LET ME TELL YOU, WE WERE AT THE
RETIREMENT DINNER, AND WE ADDED
IT UP, YOU AVERAGED 100, I THINK
HE SAID 21 DAYS A YEAR.
121 DAYS A YEAR, 36 YEARS, PLUS
AS VICE PRESIDENT, BOOM BOOM,
YOU'VE TRAVELED OVER
2 MILLION MILES, I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR ANYMORE ABOUT THE
AIR FORCE.
>> Sean: WHY TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN AND THE AMERICAN HE
ABANDONED OR HIS DISASTER AT THE
BOARD OR BEGGING OPEC FOR ENERGY
OVER THE DISASTER KNOWN AS THE
BIDEN ECONOMY.
THAT BIZARRE, THAT RAMBLING
STORY, NOT EVEN TRUE, ACCORDING
TO MULTIPLE MEDIA OUTLETS AND
FACT-CHECKERS, BUT THAT NEVER
STOPS JOE BIDEN FROM REPEATING
ONE LIE AFTER ANOTHER, IN THIS
CASE ON FIVE SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
AND EVEN WORSE, APPARENTLY
JOE BIDEN NOW BELIEVES HE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR, GET THIS, 36
YEARS.
>> A LOT OF THE FOLKS AT AMTRAK
BECAME MY FAMILY, NOT A JOKE.
I WOULD RIDE EVERY DAY.
I COMMUTED EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR
36 YEARS AS VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AFTER MY WIFE
AND DAUGHTER WERE KILLED, I WENT
HOME TO SEE MY FAMILY, NEVER
STOPPED GOING AND DOING THAT.
>> Sean: 36 YEARS AS
VICE PRESIDENT.
OKAY.
I THINK IT IS PRETTY CLEAR TO
EVERYONE WATCHING, JOE BIDEN IS
NOT WELL.
THIS MAN SHOULD NOT BE OUR
PRESIDENT.
HE IS NOT MENTALLY, COGNITIVELY
STRONG ENOUGH, NOT FIT TO SERVE.
AND BY THE WAY, HE ALSO HAS
BLOOD ON HIS HANDS AS A RESULT
OF HIS DECISION IN AFGHANISTAN,
SOMETHING HE SAID HE WOULDN'T
DO, AND NOW, BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S
OBVIOUS DECLINE, HIS RADICAL
BASE, THEY ARE CALLING ALL THE
SHOTS, THEIR NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISM IS DESTROYING THE
ECONOMY, HIS POLICY ON ENERGY IS
KILLING EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY IS
PAYING MORE FOR EVERY ITEM WE.
A LOOK AT THIS, TONIGHT'S
AMERICAN LABOR SHORTAGE IS SO
BAD, DOMINOES CAN'T FIND DRIVERS
TO DELIVER ITS PIZZAS.
GROCERY STORE SHELVES, YEAH,
THEY ARE GOING COMPLETELY EMPTY,
AND THAT IS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE CARGO SHIPS THAT HAVE
BEEN ANCHORED OFF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA NOW FOR MORE TIME
THAN IT TOOK THEM TO CROSS THE
PACIFIC OCEAN.
YOUR CHRISTMAS PRESENTS PROBABLY
ARE NOT GOING TO ARRIVE IN TIME
FOR CHRISTMAS, AND YOU ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO YOUR KIDS
WHY SANDO WAS BEING SO MEAN THIS
YEAR.
INFLATION IS AT A 30-YEAR HIGH,
EVEN CNBC IS FORECASTING THIS
LOOMING RECESSION.
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THIS NEW
BUILD BACK BETTER, NEW GREEN
DEAL SOCIALISM SPENDING, THAT
WILL ONLY EXACERBATE ALL OF
THESE VERY SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
THAN TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE,
WELL, JOE IS ABOUT TO FIRE
THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS AND NURSES
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND COPS AND
SOLDIERS AND FIREFIGHTERS
BECAUSE OF HIS RIGID VACCINE
MANDATE THAT WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE EVERY PROBLEM IN THE
ECONOMY WE ALREADY HAVE IN A
MAJOR WAY.
AND REMEMBER, BIDEN AND OTHER
TOP DEMOCRATS, THEY ONCE
FOLLOWED NOT TO SUPPORT ANY KIND
OF VACCINE REQUIREMENTS.
WANT TO KNOW WHERE VACCINE
HESITANCY COMES FROM?
THEM.
BECAUSE THEY CHANGED THEIR MIND.
THE CDC WEBSITE CHANGES
CONSTANTLY.
THE NIH, FLIP-FLOP FAUCI,
JOE BIDEN, ALL OF IT, THEY
LITERALLY HAVE CREATED AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE NOBODY
BELIEVES ANYTHING THEY SAY.
THIS MIGHT BRING BACK MEMORIES.
>> MANDATORY?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD
BE MANDATORY, I WOULD NOT DEMAND
IT TO BE MANDATORY.
>> PERHAPS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD STEP IN AT
ISSUE MANDATES, AND IF NOT, ARE
YOU PUTTING THE NEEDS OF
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE AHEAD OF THE
NEEDS OF VACCINATED PEOPLE?
>> I THINK THE QUESTION HERE,
ONE, THAT IS NOT THE ROLE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THAT IS THE
ROLE THAT INSTITUTIONS, PRIVATE
SECTOR ENTITIES, AND OTHERS MAY
TAKE, THAT CERTAINLY IS
APPROPRIATE.
ALSO, LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO TAKE STEPS THEY NEED TO
TAKE.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU WILL EVER
SEE A MANDATING OF THE VACCINES,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
>> Sean: WE CANNOT REQUIRE,
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING WE CAN DO.
OH, ALL OF A SUDDEN, I GUESS
THEY CAN DO IT.
IS IT JUST TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS OR DIVIDE THE COUNTRY FOR
POLITICAL GAIN?
WHY IS THERE NO OTHER OPTION,
LIKE MANY STATES AND LOCALITIES
HAVE ADOPTED?
WHETHER DEMOCRATS LIKE IT OR
NOT, LOOK, THE DEBATE OF VAX DO,
DON'T VAX, WE HAVE HAD THAT
DEBATE AND FOR WHATEVER REASON,
I DON'T KNOW, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE WILLING TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS, LOSE THEIR BENEFITS
COME ABANDONED THEIR RETIREMENT,
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW STRONGLY
THEY BELIEVE IN THEIR POSITION.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE RARE
CONDITIONS THAT FORBIDS THEM
FROM GETTING THE VACCINE.
OTHERS HAVE NATURAL IMMUNITY AND
THEY BELIEVE IN THE SCIENCE OF
NATURAL IMMUNITY.
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, THIS CASE WE
ARE ALL WATCHING IN ISRAEL.
IT IS GOING TO BE PEER-REVIEWED,
800,000 PEOPLE, CLOSE TO IT, AND
IT SEEMS NATURAL IMMUNITY IS
BETTER THAN THE VACCINE.
TIME WILL TELL.
LET'S FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
THE DEBATE FOR THEM, THOUGH, FOR
MANY PEOPLE, IS OVER.
THEIR MINDS ARE MADE UP.
THEY ARE WILLING TO LOSE IT ALL,
AND THEY ARE LOCKED IN.
THAT WILL TAKE OUR ECONOMY.
WE WILL SUFFER EVEN MORE.
AND WHY?
IN ORDER TO VILIFY THOSE
AMERICANS THAT WILL NOT MAKE US
ANY SAFER OR MORE SECURE?
IT IS NOT GOING TO END MY
COVID-19, IT IS NOT GOING TO
STOP THE SPREAD, BUT DEMOCRATS,
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
IT.
HOW ABOUT A SIMPLE OBJECT, OKAY,
WE DO NOT WANT YOU TO LOSE YOUR
PENSION, WE DO NOT WANT YOU TO
LOSE YOUR JOB, WE DO NOT WANT TO
BE SHORT-STAFFED, HOW ABOUT YOU
TAKE A TEST ONCE A WEEK OR TWICE
A WEEK OR WHATEVER?
BY THE WAY, WHY DON'T THEY EVER
MENTION MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES
ARE EVER TREATMENTS?
WHETHER YOU HAVE A BREAKTHROUGH
CASE OF COVID OR YOU
UNVACCINATED, IT SEEMS TO BE
WORKING WONDERS BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN NOW DID IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME ACTUALLY MENTIONED IT
BECAUSE IT WAS IT WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL USED BY RON DeSANTISN
FLORIDA.
THEY DEFINITELY DON'T CARE,
SEEMINGLY COME ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
THEY MADE THAT CLEAR.
YESTERDAY IN RESPONSE TO THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC CRISIS, AND
OPPOSITION TO THE NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISM FILLED BACK BETTER,
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
COMPLAINS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
JUST UPSET ABOUT A CHANGING
COUNTRY.
>> I THINK THEY ARE UPSET ABOUT
A CHANGE IN COUNTRY.
I THINK THEY ARE UPSET ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE CANNOT BUILD --
THAT THEY CANNOT REALLY HAVE
MAJORITY, YOU KNOW, THEY CANNOT
BE ELECTED WITH A MAJORITY WITH
JUST A VERY NARROW, HOMOGENOUS,
CLASSIST, SPACE.
AND THEY ARE SCARED.
AND THEY ARE ANGRY.
AND THEY ARE DOING ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE DISENFRANCHISE THE VERY
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THE POWER OF CHANGING THIS
COUNTRY FOR THE BETTER.
>> Sean: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE UPSET AT THE STATE OF
THE ECONOMY.
A LOT OF AMERICANS UPSET THAT WE
ABANDONED AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE UPSET AT
THE DISASTER AT THE BORDER.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE UPSET
THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS GET
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT.
NO COVID TESTING, NO VACCINE
MANDATES FOR THEM.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS ARE
REALLY UPSET IT COSTS SO MUCH
MORE TO FILL UP THEIR GAS TANK
AND HEAT AND COOL THEIR HOME,
AND OF COURSE, THE RISING
GROCERY BILLS AND EMPTY SHELVES,
AND VIRTUALLY NOBODY IN THE
MEDIA MOB IS BLAMING JOE BIDEN,
EVEN THOUGH HE DESERVES IT.
AND HE REDUCED TO COME
ARTIFICIALLY, AMERICA'S OIL AND
GAS SUPPLY, AND IN THE MEANTIME,
THE MAN REMAINED CONSTANT, THAT
MEANS THE PRICE GOES WAY UP, AND
IT HAS GONE WAY UP.
AND HE IS PAYING AMERICANS NOT
TO WORK.
WE HAVE RECORD LEVEL SPENDING
CAUSING INFLATION TO SKYROCKET.
NOW, BY THE WAY, HAWKING A
TRILLION DOLLAR SOCIALIST
SPENDING BILL, BASICALLY
STEALING FROM YOUR KIDS, YOUR
GRANDKIDS, GUESS WHAT THAT DOES
TO INFLATION QUESTION WORK THAT
WILL MAKE IT WORSE.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, THEY ARE
NOT ANGRY ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE MAD THAT
JOE BIDEN'S MESSAGING ISN'T MORE
ON POINT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO, WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
YOU?
WHY ARE YOU SO BAD AT
POLITICKING?
WHY ARE YOU SO BAD AT POLITICS,
DEMOCRATS?
WHEN YOU HAD THE WINNING
MESSAGE, WHEN YOU HAVE THE
SENATE, AND YOU HAVE THE
CONGRESS, AND YOU HAD THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND YOU CAN'T WIN
WITH A WINNING MESSAGE?
SOMETHING'S WRONG!
>> DEMOCRATS, GET YOUR BUTTS IN
GEAR AND GET PASSIONATE ABOUT
SAVING THIS DAMN COUNTRY.
YOU ARE WEAK, YOU ARE WEAK.
>> Sean: I TAKE A LITTLE
DISAGREEMENT WITH THAT WINNING
MESSAGE THING ABOUT SOCIALISM,
BUT FORGET ABOUT THE HORRIBLE
ECONOMIC CRISIS.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO SELL IT
BETTER, REALLY?
WELL, WE COME I GUESS, THE
GREEDY, SPOILED PEOPLE OF
AMERICA, I GUESS WE ALL JUST
NEED TO LOWER OUR EXPECTATIONS,
SETTLE FOR LESS, TELL YOUR KIDS
AT CHRISTMAS THAT SANTA IS MAD
AT YOU AND IT IS NOT GOING TO BE
THE SAME THIS YEAR.
WE NEED TO STO